he remains the dominant figure in the
Republican Party the former president
has declared he is once again running
America's comeback starts right now
eyeing a spectacular return to the White
House but Donald Trump may not be as
formidable as he once was
[Applause]
[Music]
Ambassador Nikki Healey who once said
she would never run against her
president has entered the race for the
Republican nomination hinting Trump is
too old for office
generation to lead us into the future
it's a battle which has come to
represent the rift cleaving the
Republican Party apart after losing the
White House in 2020 and the weak
performance from candidacy backed in the
midterms many Republicans think it's
time to move on from Donald J Trump they
desperately do not want to talk about
Donald Trump anymore they want to ignore
him or hope he gets killed by a shark or
or that gets you know struck by a
meteorite or some other outcome
um they are the Washington lobbyist
Consulting establishment that's the
Kevin McCarthy uh that's Mitch McConnell
that Hardline party loyalists are
gathering for the annual CPAC conference
the center of the Republican Universe
for four days and the divisions will be
on show Trump is the headline act he's
going to do what he did in 2016. Destroy
his Republican opponents many
presidential wannabes will be there but
they may underestimate the power Trump
still has over the party base they're
going to come with a one-liner oh Donald
you're a little bit up there and he's
going to just rip them to Pieces he's
going to go after their their own mental
acuity their own health their own
physical nature I
there are a lot of people who who are
replaying the mistakes of 2016 and 2015.
we do not surrender to the woke mob not
going Florida to Governor Ron DeSantis
the man considered the most likely to be
the main Challenger to Donald Trump and
a man who could command significant
support in the party
Republicans are almost United on one
thing they think Joe Biden is doing a
terrible job but unless they can pull
the party together put the pieces back
he may not become an ex-president as
quickly as they would like Alan Fisher
Al Jazeera Washington